بسياسه وحده اراضيها وانها جزء لا يتجزا
في مواجهه محاولات تايوان للتخلص من
التبعيه لبكين انطلاقا من حق تقرير المصير
خلاف ادى الى استمرار التوتر بين الجانبين
بل وزيادته خلال عام 2022 في منطقه بحر
تايوان والخط الفاصل المعروف باسم منطقه
اديز للدفاع الجوي وهي منطقه تشمل مساحه
اكبر بكثير والمطلوب من كل طائره اجنبيه
تحلق في داخلها التعريف عن نفسها للسلطات
الجويه المحليه سواء للصين او تايوان
وخلال العام الماضي سجلت العلاقات بين
الصين وتايوان اكبر تدهور لها منذ تسلم
الرئيس السلطه وما زاد من هوته ولجوء
تايوان استقبال وفود برلمانيه من الدول
الغربيه كان ابرزها وصول رئيسه مجلس
النواب الامريكي نانسي
فكففت الصين نشاطتها العسكريه قرب تايوان
واطلقت اكبر مناوراتها منذ سنوات مقارنه
بالاعوام السابقه وفقا لوكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه
حيث بلغ عدد الطائرات التي نشرتها الصين
قرب تايوان في عام
طائره مقارنه ب 960 طائره في عام 2021 و
بين عامي 2021 و 2022 ازداد عدد توغل
الطائرات المقاتله الصينيه باكثر من الضعف
من
538 طائره الى
1141 طائره وارتفع عدد القادسات ومنها اتش
6 ذات القدرات النوويه من 60 الى ما يزيد
على مئه قادفه
وفي ظل هذه الارقام الاخذه في الارتفاع
يبقى خلاف تايوان الصين قائما كما هو
مصحوبا بحاله ترقب دولي واقليمي خاصه مع
تمسك الولايات المتحده بدعم عسكري
واقتصادي لتايوان راغبه في الانفصال
وبالنسبه للصين غالبا ما تكون التوهلات
الجويه وسيله للتعبير عن الاستياء من
سياسات تايوان علي السمان العربيه